my mom and dad are getting back together
we're hiding from you so you don't kill
her and instead of doing that will you
just go away
are there like infinite timelines came
no matter what Rick does to try to
consolidate his power he's learning
about the futility of it there's always
gonna be something that's going to get
in the way I brought this here to kill
cherry Christ you win you win Jerry when
a journey this season and really worked
on himself and became a better person
and that was personified in that moment
when he wanted to recreate the innocence
of Jerry and about the first date
instead of just taking advantage of a
confused path you know me inside and out
do what you have to do and of course of
doing that they reconnect and she's
convinced these feelings she had for
Jerry are real his stupidity allows for
concepts like romance he loves me only
an idiot could love me the love of Beth
and Jerry has somehow trumped all of the
[ __ ] Rick does and is the culmination of
a season that started with Rick saying
nobody [ __ ] with me I destroyed your
marriage on purpose Jerry is back where
he belongs but happily and everyone
wants him to be there and it's Rick
who's out of step with the family now
the real question episode is is Beth a
clone or isn't she you know Rick is
repeatedly asked to answer that question
but everybody knows that Rick can't
necessarily be honest if she's a clone
so don't look for us Marty's putting his
foot down and saying you you go on from
here you become a spin-off you go find a
new Morty and you start over but without
this instance of me nobody gets it
nothing you think matters matters what
we see is that Rick concedes and he
actually bothers to put effort into a
stupid relationship with a dumb
president thereby committing to this
timeline dad you can't talk to Jerry
that way anymore we're a real family now
rick is now the lowest status person in
the family and can't do anything about
it
the real question mark going into the
next season is when you're bragging that
your family is great and everything's
gonna be streamlined what stories are we
gonna tell that makes people like that
upset and most importantly we get to pop
in on mr. poopy butthole all we see he's
doing pretty good he's got a wife it's
got a little kid seems to be in pretty
good health think he's off the meds
we've got a real problem epidemic in
this country of pharmaceutical addiction
so it's good to see that he's curbed
that issue it's pretty nice I really
like that character I'm really happy for
him and we're gonna probably check in
with him again later on and you mark my
words hey everybody so we got a first
little teaser for season four some of
the ideas for where the conflict might
flow from so even though it doesn't
sound like they said a whole lot there
actually have been some indicators for
where that's gonna come from so this
will just be a breakdown of that so if
you're finding me for the first time
we'll be doing Rick and Morty during the
off season until season four gets here
be sure to subscribe to get everything
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video - and it's New York Comic Con
week so I'll explain what's going on
with that there's some extra special
stuff happening but one of the great
things and they sort of call it out in
this video is the idea that Rick became
the villain of season 3 but because he's
not a true villain he came back from
that like when they walked the tightrope
of turning him into jigsaw during
episode 4 it becomes this really funny
thing but for a little while he actually
does seem like a legit villain way worse
than somebody like world ender who's
actually supposed to be a real villain
[Music]
the real question being why doesn't Rick
do as Morty says and just go to a
different reality and pick up with a
different Morty and start over again and
I think that's because this version of
the family is really special to him but
because he sort of called himself out as
being on the spectrum and he's an
alcoholic he has trouble processing
emotion and other people so he has a lot
of trouble fitting in in social
situations and be because of the
alcoholism is prone to violent mood
swings which the show mostly uses for
comedy but in reality that's actually a
pretty damaging thing to try and be in a
relationship with an alcoholic like that
like imagine you had a nice adventure
with someone and everything ended up
okay
and then after the fact they got super
drunk and came into your bedroom in the
middle of the night and put a knife at
your throat and passed out
[Music]
that's part of the reason why maybe
cloned Beth goes back to Jerry because
she recognizes the idiotic simplicity in
him and how much she needs that and why
she fell in love with him in the first
place
you silly simple uncomplicated man
because she's like the midpoint between
Rick and Jerry like that high
functioning genius person who's just
completely out of control in the most
basic simple person you could possibly
imagine so by the end of the season
she's gotten to the point where she's
questioned her own reality she's
swinging into Rick territory and she
swings back into Jerry territory just to
balance herself out like she needs him
in a really messed-up way and she
understands that and as part of the
equilibrium of their family like you
wonder how this family could possibly
exist with all the things that happen
but they just balance each other out and
that's part of the charm of it and so
the actual real problem that the writers
have now is that they've sort of gotten
rid of the cosmic threats like they've
gotten rid of the Federation they've
dealt with the internal conflict that
they're having like they're say okay
we're a family again we're back to
season one rick is no longer trying to
destroy their family so where is the
actual conflict going to come from the
show always does a really good job of
balancing comedy drama in science
fiction and you can't have drama without
conflict during season one you actually
did have the threat of the Federation so
even though there wasn't so much of an
internal threat initially you still had
like this big overarching cosmic threat
so at some point at the beginning of
season 4 they either have to introduce a
new cosmic threat which I think they
already have in someone like evil Morty
in a new internal threat so really when
the writers are saying your family is
great and everything is going to be
streamlined what's the threat the threat
to the family is somebody who loves
chaos the show actually does have a
couple characters like that like evil
Morty's probably the best example but
going all the way back a couple seasons
like they said they don't want to
shackle an entire season to him
we want to come back to something really
cool like like evil Morty I want to make
sure I know what's his motivation what's
this backstory what's going on and it
has to be inspired and it can't be
forced and it can't be joyless I mean
you wanted to come from a place you
don't want it to circumscribe your
narrative you don't want you don't want
to draw pin in the whole show with an
evil Morty narrative you want evil if we
the Lord he comes back he should be more
like Davidoff Winkler it's like oh I
remember him so when he came back this
year it was really just like a one-off
thing like it was just episode 7 and
then a couple mentions you know a couple
Easter eggs but that's really it so a
previous experience is any indicator
that when evil Morty comes back he'll
still have some really evil plan but
it's not like he's gonna be in every
single episode so I feel like the only
thing you can do without just going
straight back to evil Morty or Tammy and
birdperson is to just have Rick slowly
slide back into his old habits like this
equilibrium that they achieve in this
episode to slowly devolve back into what
you saw over the course of season 1 but
maybe not right away like they'll
probably pick up an episode one with a
like bickering that they have in those
first couple of episodes way back like
if you really watched season 1 it took
them a couple episodes to find the
format of the show but they always did
do a good job with these family scenes
it's just the difference in the way they
structured the stories that change from
season 1 to season 2 hold on a second
Rick you wouldn't by any chance have
some sort of crazy science thing you
could whip up that might help make this
dog a little smarter would you I thought
the whole point of having a dog was to
feel superior Jerry if I were you I
wouldn't pull that like they've gotten
to the point where they do a much better
job of weaving the a story in the B
story together like you used to have the
a story which was the adventure that
Rick and Morty would go on that was the
sci-fi a story then you would have the B
story which was sort of whatever was
going on with the family in each episode
so I don't think that the types of
stories that they tell is going to
change I think they'll just feel like a
single story with a bunch of different
threads that work together a little bit
better than they have in previous
seasons I know there are all kinds of
Christmas episode conspiracy theories
the writers have shot down Christmas
this year the odds now are if there's
going to be a Christmas episode per mr.
poopy butthole then it would have to be
next Christmas but I actually don't
think it's gonna take them that long to
get it out I think they're just giving
themselves that much
so that if down the road something
happens and there is a delay fans don't
come back and say hey wait a minute you
said it was gonna come out way earlier
than this and get way pissed off at them
but if we do get any legit production
updates I'll just include them in any
bonus videos that I do so there'll be
some new Rick and Morty in the next
couple days if you have any special
requests just leave them in the comments
below it's New York Comic Con this
weekend so there's gonna be a whole
bunch of comic book trailers and related
stuff dropping I'll do videos for as
much stuff as possible
big Justice League trailer on Sunday
though that's probably the biggest one
there's a new round of that Zen monkey
Studios merch giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the winner from the last video Jedi owl
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for my other season 4 video and you can
click here for a brand new flash footage
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]